[Music]  in a town just like your town if your  town was a dream that's beautiful  live the grumpiest grouch the world has  ever seen  [Music]  you're mean one mr. Grinch you as cuddly  as a cactus you uh what's back as an eel  this degree and checkmate again  [Music]  the mayor was Christmas to be three  times bigger this year for 53 years  Christmas has brought me nothing but  misery what do I become Santa Claus to  steal their Christmas sir if he could  deliver it in one nightstand I can steal  it what Santa heaven I don't that's  hurtful this perfectly recreates a  mating call of the reindeer the home oh  hey there sorry little goat I was  calling for a wreck  Wow  the Grinch  [Music]  possessed loudest snow I never heard it  my life what are you doing  [Applause]  okay  [Applause]  [Music]  you